hello everyone and welcome to a game
i've known existed for quite some time
now but i've never shown it because
uh well there was just uh never enough
proof that the game
ever actually happened uh now it's a
game between uh charlie chaplin
and samuel rushevsky both of them
extremely famous similar rusevski legend
in the chess world
and charlie chaplin a legend in the
world in general
in in in those days in 1923 uh when the
game was played
uh definitely amongst the the top few
most famous people in the world now this
is supposedly a game from 1923 from a
simultaneous exhibition in new york
uh and uh samuel rushevsky uh held a lot
of
simultaneous exhibitions here is one of
the uh famous images that goes around
here is him
uh holding a simultaneous exhibition and
he did this a while he was known as a
prodigy
and here is also a game of two of them
playing so here is
charlie chaplin and uh young simulator
chefs a bit older here in the photo
than the one i'm using in the profile uh
photo this one is uh
two years younger probably than when the
game uh allegedly took place now
why am i only showing it now when i've
pretty much shown every game
known to men that was played between
celebrities uh well it's because uh
chess historian olympia urkhan uh posted
on twitter that
vladimir kramnik who recently joined
twitter
posted about this game and he did some
research on the game and
he is able to shed some light on the
matter whether the game
actually happened or not so i'm going to
show you the game but i will put a link
to his patreon page in the description
below it will be the first thing you
will see where you can read
a bit more about what happened here and
uh you know his
thoughts as he is the chess historian
about whether the game actually took
place but i will
uh try and make sense of the actual game
and
try and uh figure out uh well is it even
possible that such a game
uh ever took place because uh i i've
done
uh the research uh not a lot i've you
know
i did some browsing let's uh you know
say it as it is
but i i haven't seen anyone actually say
that the game
didn't take place so they say like it's
very unlikely that the game took place
but i i haven't seen anyone saying that
the game actually didn't take place so
first let's see the game
and then decide whether it is possible
that this is actually a game between
charlie chaplin and samuel rushevsky
so without further ado let's check it
out charlie goes for
e4 and we have e5 so nothing out of the
ordinary here we have knight to f3 and
knight to f6 so young samuel goes for
the uh petrov defense
knight to f6 and d4 now now
uh is it odd that a d4 move is played
here for 1923 definitely not if um
basically if you've just known the
basics of chess and you know some
general chess principles
uh you know that you have to you know
develop your pieces early and
take take the center very early on even
at the cost of
sacrificing some pawns so this is all
just uh
still just a very very general chess
knowledge so e captures on d4
and now e5 grabbing some space so
playing like this
it would require some some theory
but let's see how the game continues we
have knights to e4
and now queen to e2 again uh
doesn't really make sense to block your
own light square bishop like this
but if you've decided to castle
queenside and you want some extreme
rapid development you're already
attacking blacks knight
it it can make sense so here we have
knight to c5 rashevsky moves back the
knight
and knight captures on d4 now
recapturing the pawn with knight the c6
attacking the knight and the pawn here
and well you could uh
trade trade pieces here just bishop to
e3 again going for very rapid
development and um
uh well you are white you don't want to
be behind in development
uh with knight captures on v4 bishop
captures on d4
and now knight to e6 again attacking the
bishop here
bishop back to c3 and now bishop to e7
there is one game from 1966
uh that reached this exact same position
where d5 was played but here we have
bishop to e7 by young samuel
uh and it is as of move nine that this
position has never been
reached again so let's see uh how the
game uh continued we have knights to d2
preparing uh the castle queen side here
uh and the
reschevsky uh castle's king side we have
knights to e4
uh and here d5 just going after that
knight
uh forgot to mention uh at the beginning
of this game
and i'm gonna mention it now before
because now it's where
things really uh get uh crazy uh charlie
was
uh uh charlie was around 36 when this
game was played and young samuel was
about 12 when the game was played so
just uh thought i'd mention that as well
so here d5
attacking the knight and e captures on
b6 alpha son
does does seem like the way to go
however
here we have the instant queen side
castle and it does make sense in a way
that you are now preventing capture
as the queen is being behind the rook
and the d-file uh however it is a very
very risky move so here bishop to d7 now
capturing is definitely an
option and knight back to g3 so again
it does make sense you don't have to
like really know a lot of theory to play
like this you just need to
understand the basic principles of chess
and how how
important rapid development is but even
even if you know all of that it would
still be
very hard to play like this uh if you
don't know
anything if you don't at least waste a
little bit of your time on chess
uh so here of course uh you you will
now get uh ready to maybe play king to
b1 in the future somehow you want to get
this spawn rolling up the board
uh and so on and here ereshevsky goes c5
he wants to play b5b4 and
start a queen side attack with bishop
back to d2
now not allowing d4 as d4 would attack
the bishop either way but also keeping
an eye on the f4 square you now
can play f4 and f5 and go for some sort
of a kingside attack with b5
and now not going for f4 uh
continuing in this style but rather
knight to f5
and here yes you your knight is very
close to the black king like you have
some ideas maybe queen g4
with checkmate to follow if this knight
ever moves
uh but okay uh black just continues with
d4 he says my attack is happening much
faster
we have h4 by chaplin and now uh we have
knight to c7 re-maneuvering the knight
over to d5
and from there the knight will truly be
uh well a monster knight you can come to
the c3 you can sacrifice it to open up
uh
alliance in front of the white king and
so on and also the knight is now under
attack
on f5 so here uh chaplin captures on e7
so captures captures
and bishop to g5 now putting pressure on
the queen here
queen to e6 attacking the a2 pawn so
there's always that and the king to b1 a
nice prophylactic move
uh well not prophylactic here as you are
you have to play it to defend
so it's not a prophylactic move but uh
uh i also
enjoy it very much because it's much
stronger than b3 weakening your
your queen side so here we can also
learn a little bit about uh how strong
uh uh charlie was if this game
ever actually happened so king to b1
defending the a2 pawn
and now knight to d5 now there's a lot
of
pressure happening here like the king
and queen are here knight to c3 you
constantly have to keep an eye on that
uh and white's attack is nowhere uh
it's not even happening and it's uh well
you require at least two three moves to
to start to start the attack and here we
have g3 a move that
um not really in the spirit of the
position
uh really i mean uh black is coming for
you you you
you want to start the attack you don't
want to play some positional chess here
uh bishop to g2 of course is the idea of
putting some pressure along this
diagonal
but it is much too slow knight to b4 now
already putting pressure on the a2 pawn
so here b3 but this only weakens your
uh position and now queen to a6 by uh
reshefsky going after that a2 pawn
with a for defending and now queen to a5
and this is a really really
beautiful position because a lot of
things are possible here
uh for example if uh white goes for
something like bishop to e7 attacking
the rook and the c5 pawn
uh you can just give up the rook b
captures on a4 and after characters here
you can just capture on b3 and it's
uh it's a massacre there's uh no way you
can defend against this if you capture
to guard the a2 pawn with your queen
uh the a2 square then bishop f5 check
king c1
and now comes queen to a1 check that's
that's just game king d2 queen to c3
will be checkmate
as uh well you you have nowhere to go so
here after queen to a5 we have king to
b2
uh getting uh the king to the second
rank now rook to a1 will be an idea
but still just b captures on a4
and okay rook to a1 pinning the a pawn
as now captures would happen
uh rook 8 to b8 now getting the rook to
the b
file not really worried about anything
here as the bishop also guards the a4
pawn
king the c1 getting the king away from
the b file and now
a3 there are a lot of possibilities here
you could try and bust open the position
with c4 for example queen captures rook
after c8
ideas like that but a3 creates a pass
pawn it's
incredibly strong you're very it's very
unlikely that you will get this rook
ever into the game and it's just a
terrible position for white so here we
have bishop back to d2
uh pinning the knight here and now
bishop to e6
now with ideas of of pushing this pawn
uh so here we have bishop captures on b4
trading down a little bit and here you
could capture with everything you you
could capture with the queen you could
capture with the c
pawn uh but uh we have c characters on
b4
by uh young reschevsky with queen to a6
now offering a queen trade
and it does make sense to do all of this
yes you're down upon
maybe maybe you can survive this but you
definitely want to trade queens
however queen to c5 again uh there's
constant pressure bishop captures on b3
now the idea because the c2 pawn is
pinned
and white needs a way to defend this we
have bishop to c4
now of course if captures the queen can
just capture in the white white can
still dream
of maybe surviving this however here we
have rook
beat the c8 sorry uh that's not a rugby
rook beat the c8
and it was in this position that charlie
chaplin resigned
the game allegedly uh as there is
nothing more to be done here and
this is what really fascinates me
because uh to resign here
i mean you don't have to be a really
strong player but you have to
know how to play chess like decently to
to resign here to like you know throw in
the towel uh because
uh well you you someone might play a few
more moves or maybe
maybe some more moves were played and as
this was a simultaneous
exhibition maybe uh more moves than this
were not published
i i i have no idea about that but if
this
this is the entire scoresheet uh then it
is it is a bit odd because here
resigning
is the sign of a stronger player because
for example
let's say you try and trade queens here
queen b5 then you run into the pretty
much
the same idea as well there's the
problem of the pin along the c file
captures captures and captures and now
it's just uh
completely winning for uh for black but
again you have to be
a stronger stronger player to realize
this and another thing after rook b the
c8
uh you could go for let's say the queen
is also putting pressure on the pawn
here so you might play
f4 but then you allow this d3 idea
now that's not the only idea there are
many ideas here but now
queen here is the the problem and
there's not much if bishop captures then
you can just go
with a bishop captures here also a
possibility
and if you don't if you play with pawn
captures then you just go in for a
mating attack
it's it's a forced animating idea queen
e3 check king c2
you now go for another check we need to
check king c1 queen b2 checking d1 and
now bishop to g
for check king e1 and now of course
queen to e2 will be checkmate
so the here after rook beat the c8 uh uh
charles chaplin resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
and a wonderful victory with the black
pieces for
young samuel rashevsky like i said if
the game ever actually happened
so far i haven't found anyone saying
that
it didn't happen they say it's very
unlikely that it happened
even though the two of them knew each
other they uh
you know took some photos in front of a
chess board
like the one that we've shown here uh
and while it is possible that the game
was played maybe it was not played in
quite the exact same setting maybe in a
simultaneous exhibition like
like it's mentioned here maybe it was a
friendly game or or maybe
it was a similar game or maybe even if
it happened
maybe reychevsky uh also helped uh
charlie with some of the moves and maybe
you know a lot of things are possible
but it's very interesting how olympia
can says
uh that he's been trying to find an
actual source for this game
score but despite the increased pace of
digitization
uh searches in historical newspapers
have proved unfruitful
but you know we might learn more about
this but uh
until then do check out the entire
article it will be the first thing you
see in the description below
uh to learn a bit more about uh well
about the mere possibility that
this game ever actually took place
uh so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh
and uh the the reason why i've only
decided to show it now
uh i would like to thank jared linder uh
richard knapp uh william right out
adam deutch and roger partington for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
or whenever we have an
interesting uh you know i uh uh
discussion ideas such as this one
so uh thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day